I have a question about the lymphatic system and all the detoxing. I mean I
guess with everything that we're doing like I'm doing the infrared sauna and
then the rife and then the food and the juicing and animals. So a lot of
detoxing so I get bouts of fatigue you know overall I feel good and then I'll
get bouts of fatigue and then when I was at my functional doctor on the bio
resonance machine it showed my lymphatic was sluggish. I jump on the trampoline.
So my question is can the detox of course make us fatigued and can it slug up
the lymphatic system? Good question. All right so what is detoxification? So detoxification
is getting bad things out of your body that we don't want to their body, right? So
where is what what are where are these bad things that we're trying to get out of
the body? So every day detox is what's taking place. So let's take a step back. In a
perfect world you're exposed to different toxins. So even 300 years ago you're
exposed to toxins. Maybe not the same ones that we were exposed to now. There was no
mud, said to, there was no fertilizer, there were no chemical spread on fields but
there was coal burned for heat all the time. So there was a lot of byproducts of coal in
the air. You look at old pictures of cities and they're black in the city, the bricks
of the building were black and such because coal was burned everywhere. There were other
toxins that they were exposed to. Not maybe so many harmful chemicals but there was exposure
to a lot of different toxins. That being said, it is imperative that your body is detoxifying.
So if you breathe that coal dust in, it went into your bloodstream and into your bloodstream
then it went through the liver and it went through that phase one, phase two, phase two
point five dumped into the bile dumped into the small attested dumped into the toilet.
And as long as by those pathways were ample enough to deal with the amount of toxic exposure,
I'd ever became toxic because what you eat, what you absorb, you are what you don't get rid
of. So as long as I was on a daily or weekly basis, getting rid of all the things that I was
exposed to, then those things never stated my system and I never became quote unquote toxic.
That is why there were less amounts of cancer back 300 years ago. And if you took out the factor
of birth deaths at birth, deaths at early age, or deaths below the age of sex, people were
living just as long 300 years ago as they are now. So don't buy this if you're getting more cancer
because people are living longer because that's not true. So if you're getting rid of everything
that you're exposed to on a weekly basis, then you're not getting them, you're not toxic.
What do you mean? How would I be toxic? Well, if I'm not getting rid of everything that I've
exposed to on a weekly basis, these toxins circulate through the blood and I will either die or my body,
my body will shunt these toxins to my cells. And that's what happens. So toxins are not getting
through the pathways because we're exposed to it over abundance of them or the pathways aren't
working correctly. So the toxins are shunted to a cell and then those cells store toxins, heavy
metals, poisons, chemicals, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. So all these chemicals that we're
exposed to are settled in the cells. That's how cancer starts. So dide-de-dide percent of the time,
they don't cause cancer. And I could live to 120 years old and die and then have somebody cut
open a slice of my body, smear a cell slice onto a slide and look at it under a microscope,
electron microscope would say, wow, look at all these hydrocarbons, look at that benzene that's in
that cell. Look at the mercury, look at the lead. Oh my gosh, this guy was full of toxins.
But as long as it didn't interrupt any of the metabolic pathways, it didn't cause disease.
Problem is it interrupts the metabolic pathways a lot. And if it interrupts the metabolic pathway in
the nucleus of the cell that is essential for cell replication, that's what's called cancer.
So if mercury in my cell interrupts my cell replication cycle, it's caused cancer.
So we need to detox. Well, how do we detox? Well, we have to improve phase 1, phase 2, phase 2.5,
phase 3 detoxification pathways. And we do things like everything that I have you guys doing that
will also help my cell, my cells push stuff back into the blood so it can detox. Now, my cells aren't
always going to push things back into the blood. They're going to push things outside of the cell
membrane. So, membrane cells are this little round thing that has membrane around it. And when we're
getting rid of the toxins in that cell, it pushes it outside of that cell, outside through the cell
membrane into this space called the extracellular space. That's the space between the cells.
The extracellular space is a fluid matrix with proteins and a bunch of junk that the cells just
gave off because they're trying to clean themselves out. And then that extracellular space is drained
by an open-ended capillary system called your lymph system, which you can think of as a storm sewer.
So, your cells are like houses that are throwing the garbage out into the street. And now the
garbage has to be cleaned up and take it away. Otherwise, we just have a whole bunch of garbage
sitting in our street, aka the extracellular spaces. And that doesn't make us feel good.
So, we could get a sick feeling, tired, sluggish, not feeling well because we are detoxing very well,
the cells, but we're dumping it in an extracellular space. And if we have an overabundance that our
lymphatics are draining well, then we could have sluggish feeling dead. And we could also have sluggish
feeling if our lymphatics are working, but it's getting back to the liver and phase 1, phase 2, phase 2.5
isn't working well. And we've talked about that a lot. That's why we use things like milk,
and nerve 2 accelerator, and keep what accelerator and pump what assist at detox accelerator,
and phosphatinal coli collated, subbitters, and binders. And that's why we're doing all that stuff.
So, you've got to look down the line. Is it a problem with the liver cell itself?
Is it a problem with the liver getting it into the bile? Let's look a little farther back.
Is it a problem with the lymphatic system being able to pick it up?
Is it a problem with the toxins that are getting it into the lymphatic system, but it's not getting
back to the blood? Well, how does the lymphatic system work? Well, the lymphatic system works by
contraction of the muscles. So, if all we're doing is sitting around on the couch,
eating healthy bond buds, we're still not going to detox very well because we're not getting lymphatic
drainage in the lymphatic movement. But you said, I'm doing the soda, I'm doing the Chiba
sheet, I'm doing skin brushing, I'm doing exercise, I'm contracting muscles, but I'm feeling sluggish.
You could be doing everything right in the symptoms that you might be getting there because
you're really doing a good job of cellular detoxification. And it's you're kind of overwhelmed with
the liver, but you're doing everything right. And this too shall pass. And you're cutting out and
go through that a little bit too. So, you might think about a couple things. Well, I've been doing this
for a couple of months and I'm still getting sluggish. You could slow down on some of those things.
And just take it easy. And maybe you're going too fast and overwhelming your liver. So,
that we need to support the liver anymore. We're just going too fast and overwhelming.
And see if that makes a difference. But you've got to look back at all the pathways that go
whereby, maybe over deleted, whereby, where do I need some support? Maybe I don't need any support.
I just need to drink some water and cool off for a little bit. Try some of those things.
Okay, thank you. That's very good.